LUIS HECTOR CHAVEZ:
Hello, everyone.
Welcome to Google I/O. My
name is Luis Hector Chavez
and I'm one of the engineers
in the Chrome OS team.
Maybe you saw today's
earlier announcement
that we're bringing Android
apps to Chrome books.
Yay.
So I'm super excited to be
here because I can finally
tell you guys what
we've been working on
for the last few months.
So it's not a secret anymore.
All right, so
first of all, let's
talk a little bit about
why we're doing this
and why it should be
interesting to you.
First of all, Chrome OS
is a growing platform.
While overall PC
shipments are declining,
Chrome OS continues to grow.
In fact, last year we had
32% year over year growth.
The numbers get even
better in certain segments.
For instance, Chromebooks
are the number one device
in K-12 edu in the US.
There are millions
of active users
with more than 50 different
devices from 13 OEMs in 44
countries, and we've got lots of
amazing Chromebooks coming out.
OK, so we have a
large, growing platform
with a large number of
potentially new users.
This is where you
Android Developers
come into the picture.
All Android developers
want more users.
All Chromebook users
want more apps,
but they just
don't want any app.
They want the apps
they know and love.
So we believe that bringing
Android apps to Chromebooks
provides a middle ground that
helps both groups of people.
OK if a developer wanted
to bring their application
in Chromebooks, what
are their options?
Let's start with a non-solution.
You can write a Chrome OS app.
This is essentially writing
your application twice.
This requires you to learn
a new platform, which
might yield an application
that looks more native,
but it's a lot of work.
It's a lot of
upkeep, and you need
to maintain two potentially
separate code bases.
So it's not an option
for most people.
Another option was to
build an HTML5 application.
This might yield an application
that looks and feels
native in Chrome
OS, but you would
need an Android
HTML wrapper, which
doesn't look super native.
It also doesn't take a lot
of advantage of the Android
platform.
So it's still not
a great option.
Another option was App
Runtime for Chrome.
We in the Chrome OS
team released this
2 years ago in 2014 as a way
to run Android applications
in Chromebooks.
We're running full
Android instances
in a Native Client sandbox.
Unfortunately, it had some
challenges for developers.
Access to some of
the system resources
were restricted due
to the advanced nature
of Native Client sandbox.
For instance, we had to
do a full file system
emulation because it
was not available to us.
And some apps didn't
work great with this.
Native Client also had a
single process execution model,
which caused some applications
to not work great, especially
the Google Play Store.
Finally, some of
the features that
are critical for developers,
like in-app payments,
required extra work
on your behalf.
Having said all that,
we still believe
that getting Android
applications running
as a fully integrated
native Chrome OS apps
was the right idea, so we
made a lot of improvements
and we're building a
whole new platform to run
Android apps on Chromebooks.
All right, so many
of you might have
missed today's earlier demo,
so I'm going to give a shorter
one right now.
OK, so first of all, this is
standard Chrome OS desktop,
but you can see we have
the Play Store now.
Yay.
And, of course, I
don't have internet
so there's no Play Store.
But fortunately I already
installed a few apps
like Gmail.
Ta-da.
So one of things
we're doing here
is that we do have
multi-window support.
And not only that, we can also
change the size of the window.
We can also maximize
it, stuff like that.
Neat things.
We also support integration
with some Chrome OS
native notifications-- for
instance, hello, world!
And, of course, as I mentioned
before, I don't have internet,
so let's skip that.
Oh, there you go.
So as we see, we can have
offline access in Android apps
now.
Right let's go
back to the slides.
OK, we already saw
what it looks like,
so let's talk a little bit more
about how it's implemented.
First of all, we're not
using Native Client anymore.
We're using a brand new
sandboxing mechanism.
It uses existing
Linux namespaces
to isolate Android
and Chrome OS.
These are you already
used in Chrome OS
and in some of our
cloud offerings.
We're using that mount,
process, user, network,
and IPC namespaces.
The core security team
also developed new features
for this.
Since Android is
running directly
on top of the Linux kernel, this
increased the attack surface
a little bit more than
we were comfortable with,
so the Chome OS security team
developed a new way to add
alternate sys call tables.
This is more efficient
and configurable
than existing system
call filtering techniques
like seccomp-bpf, which, by
the way, the Chrome OS team
also developed.
Having both Android
and Chrome OS
do their own compositing
would make everything slower,
so we have a shared compositing
model where there is only
one overall compositor.
This makes things a lot
faster and more responsive.
Finally, since we know that
a lot of developers target
indicate for arm only, we're
providing just-in-time binary
translation so that their
already existing arm
applications can run on
x86 devices like the Google
Chromebook Pixel with no
work required on your part.
So this new approach still
maintains a high level
of security in both
operating systems.
You get to keep all of
Chrome OS' security features
like verified root, user data
encryption, continuous updates,
and Android still has
[INAUDIBLE] Linux running.
There are no virtual machines
or emulation going on,
so you get full
native performance.
And finally, since we're running
the whole Android system,
you get to run all of Android
Marshmallow within Chrome OS.
This includes the
Google Play Store.
So something that we learned
with App Runtime for Chrome
is that integration matters.
The more integrated the apps are
with the rest of the operating
system, the better
they look and feel.
So we only grant
direct hardware access
to Android in very
few locations.
The rest of the
time, the hardware
is still managed by Chrome OS.
But still, we had a lot
of integration points
so that Android developers
can still call the same APIs,
and those APIs underneath
will make calls to Chrome OS.
This allows both
operating systems
to share the same
view of the system
instead of having split views.
OK, so what does it
all translate into,
and how does it impact
your applications?
Because we're running
a full Android system,
it means that most
applications can
be running Chrome OS without
any code changes at all.
Of course, since this
is a new platform,
you might want to still
make some optimizations
and small tweaks.
But your app works
like a Chrome OS app.
Most of the things you expect
the Android system to do
will be now provided by Chrome
OS instead of being constrained
to a little window.
Every task runs
in its own window.
You get Android notifications
together with Chrome OS'.
There's just one App
Launcher in shelf.
Sign-in information
will be shared
between operating systems, so
you don't have to log in twice.
You're also able to share
files in the Downloads folder,
as well.
Hardware is also integrated
so you still get connectivity
to Wi-Fi and Bluetooth.
Camera, microphone, audio,
and video still work.
All of Chrome OS'
input mechanisms
are still plumbed
through the application,
so keyboard and
trackpad events will
be delivered to
your application,
and also touch events if
the Chromebook supports it.
Meanwhile, your
application still
behaves like an
Android application.
Since we're running
a full Android stack,
the whole Marshmallow
API is available to you.
This includes Google
Play services,
so things like
in-app payments will
be available in
consumer Chromebooks.
We're also not
adding any new APIs,
so there's nothing for
you to learn this time.
All system services are running,
and all the interactions
between the system services
and your application
are exactly like
you would expect.
This includes things like the
application lifecycle events.
Finally, the hardware is
abstracted so that you don't
need to worry about anything.
And I'm going to be
clear-- while apps
can be run in
Chrome OS, we still
require Chrome OS users to
opt in to use this feature.
We understand that there are
some scenarios in which people
don't want to enable
this just yet.
We're also providing
enterprise and education users
with additional policies
that can enforce if and which
applications can run on
the devices they manage.
All right, when is this
going to be available?
For you developers, we're
enabling this feature on Chrome
OS 53.
This should be available
in the DEV channel in June,
and 53 should be
generally available
for all users in the stable
channel in September,
so you still have
some time to prepare.
We'll start by supporting
three devices-- the Asus
10-inch Flip, the
Acer Chromebook R11,
and the Chromebook Pixel 2015.
We'll gradually bring
support to more devices
in later milestones,
so stay tuned.
And that's the URL
where you can check
which devices will be getting
support on which releases.
So stay tuned.
OK, it's great that most
applications will work out
of the box without
any node changes,
but let's take a look
at the best practices
you can take into account
so your application works
even better on Chromebooks.
There's a wide variety of
Chromebook form factors.
All of them have a physical
keyboard and trackpad.
Most of the advices
we'll be rolling out
support to have a
touch screen, as well.
Some of them are even
convertible so they
can switch between a laptop
and a tablet form factor.
While we're testing
applications, most of them,
we found out that they
already work pretty well
with keyboard and mouse.
Still, not all of them did.
So it's better
that you developers
take into account testing
with a keyboard and mouse.
Also, since there's essentially
new hardware available to you,
might as well make
the best of it.
So productivity
applications can have
things like hotkey support.
That'll make users
even more productive.
Some games even lend
themselves to be controlled
using a keyboard and mouse.
OK, now for the
important coding part.
By default, all
Android applications
set the touchscreen hardware
feature to be required.
Now, I mentioned before
that not all Chromebooks
will provide touchscreen.
So it's very important that
on your AndroidManifest.xml
you set the
android.hardware.touchscreen
feature to be not required.
This will allow your
application to appear
in the Play Store
for all Chromebooks
instead of just for the
Chromebooks that support touch.
If you go out of this
presentation with just one
thing in mind, let it be this.
All right, best practices
for multi-windows.
On laptops, everybody
uses multiple windows
for productivity given that
there are more pixels available
on the screen.
Now, I did mention
a couple of times
before that we're
supporting Marshmallow API,
and Marshmallow doesn't have
the APIs for multi-window.
I also mentioned that we
are not adding any new APIs,
so how does it work?
In order to minimize the amount
of work needed for everybody,
we are only supporting
a few layouts
that your application
already most likely supports.
First of all, we
have a landscape.
This is the default layout.
This uses a Nexus 9 aspect
ratio and device [INAUDIBLE].
We also support portrait,
which runs just like a Nexus 5.
We also have maximized
windows, which
take up all available
pixels in the screen.
Finally, for
convertibles, we have
touch me mode, which is more
or less the same as maximize,
but hides the window decorations
and the shelf at the bottom,
so it's similar to
Android's immersive mode.
We added some window controls
to toggle between all
the available layouts.
This allows both
users and developers
to choose the right balance
of information density
in the sizes and layouts their
applications were originally
designed for.
Now, some things you
need to be aware of.
Similar to [INAUDIBLE]
multi-window implementation,
we're not changing the
application lifecycle model.
Exactly one application will
be on the onResume state,
and this is the window
that's currently focused.
All the rest of the
windows and applications
are in the onPause state.
Also, the out-of-memory
killer is integrated
with the rest of the
operating system,
and it takes the z
order of the windows
into account when
calculating the final score.
So applications that have
been least recently used
will be killed first.
OK, so since changing
orientation also
changes the physical size of
your window or of the device,
you need to declare the
correct Android screen
orientation so that it only
uses the ones it supports.
Now, it's also
important that you
go read this document,
the Handle Runtime
Changes in the official
Android documentation.
There will be some
things that you
don't expect to change
whenever changing orientation.
For instance, the
screen width and height
will change in ways
you don't necessarily
expect because on
normal devices,
they only flip
between them, and here
you can have totally
different values.
Also, the density DPI
setting can change
when you switch orientation.
Also, very important-- make
sure you invalidate any cache
resources.
Since once you
change orientation,
you're effectively
changing device,
you need to make sure that
you load the correct resources
after the orientation
has changed.
Now, these two things are
still important for Android
[INAUDIBLE], so might as
well do them right now.
Also, use the correct
task affinities.
As I showed in the demo,
it's possible for a task
to launch another
activity in a new task.
This will render a new window.
But if your intention was to
have a [? modal ?] window,
you should put that
activity in the same task.
Otherwise, you might get
into application faults
that you weren't expecting.
Finally, respect
the onPaused state.
While your application
might be paused,
it's still visible, so
make sure you're not
doing any rendering
because that might
look awkward for the user.
And it will also consume
a lot of battery.
Using backup and
restore effectively
is also very important.
One of the best features
about Chromebooks
is that users can just throw out
their machines, get a new one,
login, and all their
applications and settings
will be there.
So it's not totally required
to support backup and restore,
but it's a very good idea
and users will love it.
Make sure you read the
official documentation
in Backup & Restore.
There are also some
scenarios in which
Chromebooks can be shared
amongst a large number
of users.
For instance, in
education, students
don't get their own
personal Chromebooks.
They are shared
between students.
So if you're writing
applications for education
purposes, make sure to take
this scenario into account
and be mindful of the
local storage you use.
In general, Chromebooks support
a less amount of sensors
compared to mobile devices.
For instance, most
Android developers
are used to having a GPS
device to get accurate location
information.
Chromebooks don't
have a GPS device,
but they can still
get [INAUDIBLE]
location information
through the use of Wi-Fi.
This might be enough to get the
best restaurants around you,
but it might not be enough
to just grab a Chromebook,
put it in your car, expect to
have turn-by-turn navigation.
So the recommendation is to make
sure you don't require hardware
that might not be available.
Of course, if your
application does
require some piece
of hardware that's
not available on Chromebooks,
we'll respect your decision
and not show that application on
the Play Store for Chromebooks.
There are some other
software features
that are not going to be
supported in Chrome OS.
Since we want users to have
the full Chrome OS experience,
applications that customize
some parts of the UI
will not be available.
Applications that provide custom
input methods, app widgets,
live wallpapers, or home
screens won't be supported.
Also, Chrome OS is going to be
the device manager for Android,
so applications that
declare themselves
to be the device
admins or manage users
also won't be supported.
We will be shipping initially
with Android Marshmallow,
but it's still a good idea to
focus some efforts in upgrading
to N eventually
because you'll bring
a lot of features
that will improve
desktop productivity to users.
For instance, you
will have the ability
to fully resize
activities instead
of being constrained to
one of the four layouts
we support right now.
You'll also be able to use drag
and drop between applications.
And there's going to be a new
mouse cursor API available.
So in order to
learn more about N,
you can watch these
two presentations
that aired yesterday
today here in I/O,
the What's new in Android
and Multi-Window Mode.
Also, you can consult the
official Android N Developer
Preview documentation.
OK, if we have any more
questions about this,
you can consult the
official documentation
for Android Apps
for Chromebooks.
You can also ask questions
in Stack Overflow or post
questions on the
Android G+ Community.
Now, before I go,
a lot of you tried
to get to today's
earlier announcement
but couldn't get to
it, so we're going
to redo the demo that
we gave earlier today.
So here's Katie that will
present to you the earlier
demo.
KATIE: All right,
thanks a lot Luis.
LUIS HECTOR CHAVEZ: Can
we switch to the demo?
KATIE: All right, very good.
So apologies this morning that
we are a little short on space.
So we thought with
these extra few minutes,
we could go back
through our demo flow.
So unfortunately, it'll
be a mild different second
rendition.
Hopefully a little bit better.
But here we've got a Pixel 2.
It looks like a
regular Chromebook.
Got our Chrome browser here.
But you obviously now have the
Play Store on the shelf here.
So we'll go ahead
and launch that.
So here we can actually
browse through our apps.
This looks just like the regular
Play Store, so let's go ahead
and install something.
So I think we decided Bejeweled
is a pretty good game.
Let's search for that, and
we'll go ahead and install.
Oh, and look at that.
Coincidentally,
apparently Kan's wife
is asking me to make a poster
for Kan's child's birthday
party.
So being a good
employee, let's go ahead
and reply to Kan's
wife-- I'd love to.
The great thing about the
way we've integrated Android
is we get the nice
in-line reply that you'd
expect on your
tablets and phones,
so I'll go ahead and
send that off now.
Great.
So let's go ahead and do that.
I've already installed Photoshop
Mix from the Play Store,
so we'll go ahead
and launch that now.
So that's actually a
picture of Kan's kid,
I think, feeding
a pen to Piglet.
Odd.
Anyway, I've been
told that it would
be more appropriate to put
ice cream there instead.
So we'll go ahead and try
to find some ice cream here.
So luckily from
Adobe stock, they've
got some great
photos of ice cream.
It's actually very bizarre,
like half neapolitan ice
cream with some pistachio.
But that looks kind of
big, so why don't we
go ahead-- we can
use the touchscreen
just like we'd expect.
We can go ahead and shrink
our ice cream cone down.
That's a little bit better
than a pen, I suppose.
One of the problems here,
though, is obviously now
our cone is kind
of over her hand,
so we'll go ahead
and cut out that.
We can zoom in and zoom
in a little bit more.
We can go ahead again,
use the touchscreen.
That was a chunk
out we didn't want.
We'll go ahead [INAUDIBLE] that.
There we go.
That Photoshopping live,
not my finest work.
Probably come up in my
next performance review,
but OK, let's go ahead
and save that anyway.
All right, we're saving that.
That looks great.
So I've been told that he wants
a poster, so let's go ahead
and open up Word for that.
What's really nice about
this is I can now just go--
and I've got regular Word
here, throw in some photos
for Leanne's birthday party.
There we go.
That looks pretty good.
So I want to now give
this back to Kan's wife.
So let's go ahead and we
can click that we want
to share this as an attachment.
Go ahead, open up the Gmail.
We hear that's a
pretty good product.
And go ahead and
send this off to Nan.
That looks great.
Let's go ahead
and send that off.
Oh, what do you know?
Just coincidentally, someone is
attacking me on Clash of Clans.
So again, with how we've
integrated the Android
framework, chat has just worked.
This is Shahid right here.
We'll go ahead-- we better
go check out our village.
So Clash of Clans.
We go ahead and close Photoshop.
We don't need that anymore.
Go ahead, get Clash of
Clans rolling for us.
Oh dear.
You guys have never, ever
seen a demo not work on stage.
We'll go ahead-- we actually
have a slight known bug here.
Any case, though, we'll go
ahead and continue on from that.
Apologies there.
Another great game other
than Clash of Clans,
which I also like a
lot, is Galaxy on Fire.
Here we're able to get the
nice use of a desktop GPU.
Everything's super smooth.
I don't know if it looks
super nauseating to you
all in the audience, but anyway,
very good performance here
as well.
With that, I can also do
in-app purchase, as well.
So we can go direct, we
can go into buy an add-on.
And go ahead and click Buy.
And now this will be
available on my phone--
payment successful, great--
as well as my tablet, as well.
So again, this was just a
quick view of what we also
showed this morning.
We are, of course, very excited
to be working with all of you
to bring your apps
to Chromebooks.
So thank you very much.
LUIS HECTOR CHAVEZ: All right,
that's it from both of us.
Enjoy the rest of the show.
If you have any questions,
ask them of the Spaces app,
or we'll be hanging
around down the stage.
Thank you.
Bye.